In this case study,
the challenge
was to focus on one very
important characteristic
of this very flexible
electronic sensor.
And that, in fact,
is what we're going
to focus on in this
attempt to show
the flexibility of this very,
very thin film of electronics.
So I first put it on
something that is strange.
It's actually the inside
of a plastic Petri dish.
And I'm thinking that that's
showing the flexibility.
And I took another point
of view of the same set up.
I kind of liked it because
I'm very, very focused
and you can see the
bending and folding.
Then I tried something
a little more rigid,
a piece of cardboard that was
folded into a couple of areas.
I sort of like that one.
The researchers took
their own images,
which are these in
front of you, showing
that this sensor is placed on
the skin and that it stretches.
And I'm not sure about
which images are better.
These definitely showed the
stretchability and flexibility
of this very thin
membrane sensor.
Whether or not you want to
look at this for a long time is
another story, but maybe take
a look at the differences
and you make the decision.